(Forrest voice-over)
Moments after a viewer asked me
to kill someone,
I was summoned to a meeting
with my producer Grant
and Review's legal counsel.
There should've been
three vetoes.
(Grant)
Yes.
In retrospect, that is clear.
But alas.
Anyway, I just wanted to make
our position very clear.
You should not commit
a murder for the show.
Period.
I agree with that.
We don't care that it might have
been ground-breaking,
award-winning television
that people talked about
for years.
None of that matters.
We're talking about
a human life.
(Forrest)
That's--yeah. That's right.
It's a human life.
(Grant)
Even if it means
fading into obscurity,
there is no one
whose life is so worthless
that you should do this.
Yep.
(Grant)
Even if by not doing it,
eventually people go,
"Oh, yeah,
"who was that guy
back in the day, Frosty McNell?
He had a show where he
barfed up pancakes?"
And if you did do this thing,
you would be doing it
knowing that not only were you
not told to by the show,
you were expressly told
not to do it.
(Forrest)
Oh.
Okay.
Right.
- Good.
- Yeah, okay.
Yeah.
I got it. I got it.
So you're telling me
I should do this.
(both)
No no no no no.
Not at all.
Quite the opposite.
Absolutely not.
Don't do it.
Got it.
[sighs]
- Okay, thank you, Forrest.
Yeah, no, thank you.
Very good.
(attorney)
Is he gonna do it?
We have told him
not to do it.
[sighs]